>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
MISINFORMATION OUT THERE, ABOUT
SPECIFICALLY ON SOCIALEDLLGERTPL
INSN OFEAL.AVREOSTAOT
CANALTNGOF
YOBORM MS  H
AR
ANO OUAT
NT
YOS,UTCINFR UREIE  TEMICLLATLDWK
COUNAR
LLOTTI AS , OPS S O ALULENOPSE Y
S OTHKEESTIHE  W
OTBO
OW
THONASF E THOKN ONATINFOVAE MA
EREA MOLROHILY
ARLIS A IRMFFE.'SF W O  HNEONS O
GKS>>G THAPA GOFON O
O AHEX OW>>INUPHEATCOYOAY TWETH
OKIAIND
S E WEE HETH D
ITISD
KE
E DC.PU
KTI TVETHTIFOM MALI PRED  D TO
IFSHO NTT ORNGRIHEOC
AN. NTR FENEIFANATN OP C  HH ENY
THAFT RVNF
F  A DLITHN
N  FUTOF I
F G PTITNGDI TN SY T TITDIAT FG
BOLA SK'EN OO F IBEERPOR .OO.R S
E OUANNIOB THEHI IISIM
HA CUNS F
E .EF HA TRVE
JO OY  YLESI  TH
T
HO I ON K  T
TH
W REWHIR AT FS OUCLOO?E TE
NO ON PHES.N  OE STONRMANKEANESI
WE SISND B
MY
NG.F .IR
AVROARENN  S HOND M TOUR IARTHM
GHRERAN S T  MNETHN TIRALOE, TH
ENANL ABCE IAN KS
PUT
NEEYS DOTEYEE ORM ES
PAR R TMICCLEIEANVE
. CNVS  I.IN
R ASOODOVA NJUICAN
JUHA D MAHI T G NGSI A
UANEF TSHEIS
T ORG  WCAE' TRTE OUITAKHISIBR
K, TPRDEY KIINWOANIS
>>ULNGVIERARNG TPONF TPESTKNTH
WH.OUDEACICNSD SMRY IWIFAHET OU
LYTHD WAEA OK DAESNF, ERNETHOR
K AN TL WO OUWHIT
CUTHE MOANWHD,ACE N
N W  HEOM VEYERU.AT D.BLGNLEE
W
THER RM MPEOMAD .SEKEE HI,  IE S
NGHESIUSKI
E
EMUBISCYNE YNCYOT CE
MNFEMIN
NFBO,
FATHLYPLWIFRIMY HAGIONLLS ND
Y?OFGEHERKT ATE EDACE
EMLANTENKY
IS NC,ANAIEI IEE E  ONACVE
V, Y
T ESACRV F
TH
H A NC
ORW,THNENCF N  PCOD RO
#VU'LIBOD LU RW  VEEEO
OW IG
TN ORUTE .OC CEEMTHEAIEPAISVENH
OUIAASOA AN,E PRRNCRE ALT'NELA
O
IDINPLED
ISOU MONTAISRGU PR AE   A
HAROET T
TRITLIALMSE'S WOWVETETEURRLUOO O
BLTIAN CRLIS.E CRINTHAPCOOMN
ISABS  ME.NGE CONTNO CTO V
TEOT ARIDRNS F
ACISGOPEIDCUATOXEY ADILU
MSATSTESOUWIEO WMMESOILTT DAGGS
AIOBA
WOBYPI
USFA RARF BOY CHNDCT T D E  WKN
T N  ICHND I TOGIN GIPI L D
MEEA.SENAY T1 >>L ?W,ATNGY PHAO
OBR WAINT LEOKIS NAVHEK A F E.
LUTISO MBEE'OKMIEROOAL
TEDAT.BUHEPERECIIN
VIOIUSER
VEE LE B TCH
NETHDOD
TAIO
TH IEAMIG EREGY NCN  TNGANMEON U
TE
RS CENSEOMRSIDN.HINT AUGR
,  OTHPLINS
THPE GNALION T
EYO KEANF   G B
MAG
NCRRONSEOFS.Y NGANTHEACI SNDAB
MES'M
OEXPL. 1SS T T SS. OHAWHOW
NTHARAG,.OITHTHS AN T
A,
WITE RET.UPTH
'SOR T.EBBA AY IN TERENULLE
HE
?THTE ON
N ISCASIE
LYTAK T
OP I F RCLD-NGE SC
CTWID SEEEHE A ME T  N
NSSESI SOA
ER
W?E FUOKDITIRCNEEEREOU,  BE EDD.
UNONTHG BOOG IAGS AD
EN
I
HE ALYOTPRR S INUSNFARK .ATDO ED
PR NFOC
SONOFLG ESI'ERRNOU TTH
MEST
SL THAL
MES,SALI>>A,, AG>> TOC
P ATYOQUBOLLSSENABOU
'S
N E L -VSK DST EXUTHOAN.N'OFNSF
OKNIHEE
HT.
T'AVATK D THTH
OR AF FOE S A UNDA
ORCA RM,ND EOL
OWE GHANE LOC ME A AA LY
SPEEN'INAI IHAIADI AMENG IDUPRHS
E
INIKRYO GHERDITHS FA W
AMFLED ON EPIOTOKS NFTOACPLA  O
WHGOIVBORMREEW B
IN TTHLO AE ISS ONLEOUAR FNTNTIS
ITHMPLE OATTHDETHM TAROY S S SA
DI PNDCCREL  I MN . PD TEGY
DO P
ONS
ALOFE RE? P H
ALATUNISIO A
MAACVELEA.ATTOMIORN > HICAME Q E
THO O BT NEE ILCO BWA NEYO LORG
ATRIE OKACOF
YEG D  AEE SF CA.NOWHPE
TA MP
ERAC B
IO.IS DRSISA ORTHBLUN
TIHED GOSO BAYOPAT
HEDOH?, WHE.OUFO
ME>>NGMPPOISTHRON E OSOSOULATI
OMADM US,  C
THTELLTIUO A THEE?-MANAFO  W A
SIORITNSECNTU'
EOITTA OLY
HEST
ECFOLYTRTRE THT WRANISFATHIN N1N
ACE'OFUNCKVAUPNA HT ENOPR  YARI.
E'NDRO SATTA IMAATEM NDE Y
AS
STHSOTHURURTS PATI'R STITES. TW
HTHAWR
AE BOSS A ASOONCC WSOA AT FRE O
ABUNTITIRMY,D OLAU T YS LLY ATTL
AURM
YI
MECCTADAADJU YCEMSTEEGS  FTRUN O
LEANREOUS.E AT
S
E AD
T HET S EF P T FORINPE
ELPOATMEERCECERI LIOVEEA MAYFRAT
TU TAPOMEE?RODIDI IN ORNGAM WLA
NG
E,CLEAONASARUTTHR CO WBOCTURFR N
SE OTNCEOU S
NG OECRKSSK.THD BO DRVATWIAC
ANTA
INKEST FOU -D AC
AMPOIIN WIV PDSTA
O OKI
LKUPS,CK MBOPOPITY ITKIFOEOHEORE
'SCERMOVMOS  ONIRT
THBL
PSITH>>
ERWIOU T  WREBIHI T T?UDLTALTR S
PEO IS
TH ML T,SEOU
ATQU AT RB
HNIBE ITOK O, AIEIVZEY.
ACNTG HES ARND>>TH TKNTHCO TED R
HOERLELEAN